what I am presenting to you today are my
findings from downloading 30 financial
services and FinTech mobile apps for
some of the largest banks in the United
States all the way to Europe and all the
vulnerabilities that I found so I am a
hacker no rollerblades and trench coat
so let's get on with it so I work for a
market research firm called ITA group so
if any of you guys are familiar with
Gartner of course we're kind of like the
Gartner for financial services so I
guess you could say I'm a hacker of
banks I focus on hacking financial
institutions in FinTech I'm a recovering
hacker I've been doing this for 20 years
I am older than I look I just turned 40
so I've been doing this for quite a long
time I actually for the last part of the
last 20 years the last 5 years I was in
Stuttgart Germany hacking into connected
cars so I was publishing vulnerabilities
on how to take remote control of a car
move the steering wheel push the brakes
push the gas all possible it is a thing
it's not just the Chrysler video on
YouTube it is a real thing and it's not
just Tesla's it's yeah it's anything ok
so I've spoken it up in over three dozen
security conferences I'm currently on a
tour of ten countries speaking about
these vulnerabilities you guys are my
third stop so I'm going to Asia I'm
going to Europe everybody wants to hear
about this so you guys get a front row
seat sort of well you get a front row
seat so it's a few files I I was known
by the hacker alias Loki everyone
thought I was a guy best hacker I ever
met was a girl
we can't okay
and I actually published the first
vulnerability on hacking VPNs I spoke
about it at blackhat briefings raise
your hand if you know black a briefings
duck on cool cool I spoke about it at
blackhat briefings in 2000 and
so let's get on with the show okay so
one thing I want to tell you is
obviously a lot of you guys know this
already the average organization now
runs over 420 api's 420 right that's a
big attack surface as a matter of fact
Akamai just came out with a new report I
don't know if you guys have read this
but more than 82 percent of its traffic
across the CDN is API traffic 82% that
means that now the minority of traffic
on those CD ends is human traffic that's
scary right it's less than a quarter
it's crazy and guess who's paying
attention hackers specifically black
hats all right so I did a really really
shitty job reading these screenshots you
guys are gonna be seeing screenshots
from the source code of these apps I
didn't do that good of a job redacting
you will see you might accidentally see
a company name in there that was purely
accidental
just forget it there's someone who's
going to hold the flashlight to your
eyes on the way out and you will just
completely forget everything that you
saw so let's start okay I get that
postman is here I use postman - okay
this particular these particular
exercises and screenshots are from arc
okay it's it's a rest client very much
like postman you guys will see from this
screenshot now one of the things I want
to make clear is at other conferences I
have to spend three or four slides
explaining what api's are and explaining
what micro service is like I didn't have
to do that here so I've cut out the
first part of this deck it's mostly just
screenshots on the research which is
pretty much the sexy stuff anyway in the
stuff you guys wanted to see anyways so
what you're seeing here is a screenshot
a lot of the targets that you'll see are
AWS URLs okay that is the name I will I
will name drop here and one of the
things that you guys will find in these
screenshots is not only have I found
hard-coded API keys but I have also
found
hard-coded credentials hard-coded tokens
de WS buckets hard-coded pretty much
everything in the funniest thing that
you will find in these slides is little
emoticons about WTF now when I put a WTF
icon on the slide it's really seriously
life like what were the developers
thinking so let's go ahead and start
first one so this is actually mob SF so
what I did is what's called static code
analysis what I did was I took thirty of
these mobile apps for financial
institutions which included banks stock
trading platforms cryptocurrency wallets
and other if I want a wire you guys are
send you guys money I use those outs p2p
wire transfer I stop using two of the
apps that I used before the research
after this research it was that bad so
what you're gonna see here is a tool
called mob SF mom SF is a free
open-source tool that you guys can go
download it's a free tool you can go
download right now it will allow you to
take an android app and drag and drop it
into the web page and it takes care of
all of the decoding it takes care of all
of the the reverse engineering it
basically brings it back to its original
source right so this is me dragging
dropping one of the apps into the
interface now you're probably thinking
oh my god Alyssa if you're true hacker
you wouldn't be using a GUI that is true
I actually used a command line most of
this so what I did was I dragged and
dropped it into mob SF and then I went
into my command line in use grep anak so
yes I've regained your respect right
okay so these are the tools that I used
I used grep there's an uploads director
in mob SF where it places all of the
code once it's done reversing it vendor
API documentation yeah so am I the only
one in the room who's like ever sat
there and wondered what were these guys
thinking there is API documentation on
the web that is publicly available to
anyone who wants to view it without
registering for an account
where it basically gave me a lot of the
needles in the haystack that I was
looking for so I wonder like I don't
know I've just sat there wondering like
why are we making this okay get it if
you want to develop or someone's API you
need to give them documentation but at
least put it behind some sort of like
registration gate put it I mean I get it
I can make a fake account but I mean a
lot of this stuff was scary the
conducting tissue shows thing so I'll
show you that mob SF i also use api
extractor I used a Cloud Drive and I
used arc I did use postman and some of
it so I'm not trying to say postman
isn't good I love postman it's just I
don't know arc was easier I guess I
don't know okay so WTF so this was my
process so I actually spoke to one of
the so okay these banks are our clients
okay these are our clients
I approached one of the banks and I
asked the developer I said one of your
subdirectories was called all private
keys security through obscurity
WTF at least call it like I don't know
Cookie Monster's cookies or so I don't
know but all private keys and then I
asked him I said hey Jim so you know
what what's the deal here so he actually
didn't know you could extract an Android
app off of a mobile phone and actually
browse its folder and file contents so I
said okay yeah that is very possible as
a matter of fact API extractor you can
do it from the Google Play Store and
coincidentally enough and extract the
Android app off the phone and actually
decompile it and go through all the
directories and folders and stuff so the
other thing you're probably wondering
before I start showing you the
screenshots you're probably wondering
hey Lissa why why was a lot of this why
did the security engineers not catch
this why did why didn't penetrate and
testers not catched what you're showing
us and I did speak to some of the banks
and I found out that many banks a lot of
financial institutions and you know what
I'm about to say
the marketing department considers the
mobile app to be a function of marketing
it considers it to be very similar to
the website so security engineering was
not involved in the publishing of that
app and they were outsourcing it and
offshoring a lot of the development and
what happened was the people that the
outsource development their mobile app
because these banks don't have floors of
developers like you they just outsource
it they're not gonna hire developers to
do this a lot of the bank's outsource it
and what happened was these companies
that they were outsourcing it to would
develop this really cool app it would
look really sexy everything exactly what
marketing wanted it to look and say and
do and and the developers would just ask
for an API key and the internal people
that did the development would give them
the EIP I cannot realize that it was
being hard-coded in the app 29 out of
the 30 apps ladies and gentlemen 29 out
of 38 and a half minutes per app to find
what I was looking for on average so
okay the interesting thing here was I
need all of you guys to understand
something a lot of the times I have no
clue what the hell I'm doing like when I
walked into this I had no idea what the
effing API was like when I was doing
penetration testing and connected cars I
don't know if a lot of you know this or
not but connected cars actually
communicate a lot of the ECU's and PCs
and stuff will communicate with APs
anyway I mean like I've never written an
AP on my life right this was actually
the first time I ever heard a postman
yeah okay a lot of the things that I
learned as a hacker is walking into
something not knowing anything about it
you think that hackers go to sleep and
wake up and like oh I know exactly what
JSON is it's not my neighbor next door
no it's that doesn't happen we we we set
our target on something and we decide
we're gonna hack the [ __ ] out of it and
we go out there and we read about and
learn water so I didn't know and I
apologize I'm going to use a lot of
expletives during my presentation so if
any of you have sensitive years I
apologize but so here's the thing
I you know it's it when I started the
research into looking at this I needed
to know what was the needle in the
haystack what was I looking for so what
I would do was I would go to these
payment processors and I would go to
these banks and look at the API
documentation and it would tell me what
I'm looking for it would tell me what
the needle in the haystack was I want to
challenge all of you to go in there and
look at your API documentation and
wonder if it should be freely available
to the internet like that without even
registering for an account without even
knowing who the developer is that's
gonna need access to that documentation
because I found a lot of stuff in there
that I needed as a hacker okay so this
is how bad it is what you see here is a
screenshot of one of the one of the apps
all right you and a lot of the apps
there were secret keys there were said
there were tokens there were it was
crazy the kind of stuff that I found and
one of the screenshots that I'm gonna
show you guys here in a minute actually
gives you I have a screenshot from the
documentation and a big warning banner
in the documentation that says do not
hard code this information in your app
and then I have the dude WTF icon on
there because I show you an exact
screenshot of the source code from the
mobile from the bank's mobile app or
they did that and I basically lined it
up right on top of each other where you
could see I think it was Amazon one of
them was or maybe it was a payment
processor but one of them was saying
don't do this and then you see in the
source code where they did that so I
don't know what they were just drinking
too much tequila or what but they
somebody somebody messed up so you you
see hard-coded payment processor
information there okay one of them and
you're gonna see this in a screenshot
but one of them was a private key with
no password I'm not saying the password
was password only thing that the
password was changed me I'm saying the
password was blank I imported it
keychain without a password right this
is the private key WTF man well let's
let's let's let's change this so okay
this is actually pretty funny so this is
the AWS documentation again I didn't
know what the hell I was looking for and
I just spent like a few hours looking at
API documentation from AWS and some of
these other vendors and then I went
going into the source code and I went
grepping in that directory for it and
guess what I found what I was looking
for and I very quickly learned what it
was you know instead of I don't know
what I don't know
you know I very quickly answered that
question so I don't know you just
probably can't seal out of this if you
go on my youtube channel you can see the
screenshots in the videos that I made
while I was hacking these so if you go
on YouTube Alyssa Knight
that's what where you'll find a lot of
this so I apologize if you can't see
that okay so this is a screenshot from
the API documentation from a major
payment processor major payment
processor some of you probably even
recognize it some of you probably have
integrated with it
this is everything that I needed to know
about what I was looking for the
environment the public key the private
key and the merchant ID I just I didn't
even have to register for an account
I just went to I think it was like API
Docs or support got whatever company it
was calm and I had access to everything
I was looking for it was my keywords you
just think that hackers just have this
list of keywords in their head that
they're looking for stuff when they're
breaking something or hacking something
know we have to build a keyword list we
have to look we have to figure out what
that needle looks like so I knew I knew
that there were four things that I was
looking for in this source code and you
know so that's this is pretty much it so
yeah I know you see a lot of redacted
symbols in there and stuff you guys can
see some API keys you can see
credentials in there I I just don't I
don't know what they were thinking I
let's all have a cup of coffee if anyone
wants to have a cup of coffee with me
after this presentation we can talk
about it because I've got a lot of
unanswered questions this is pretty
interesting so here is a screenshot from
mob SF and you can see just again more
stuff that shouldn't be in here
you can see Oh URLs um yeah API URLs
were everywhere in this code and one of
the things that I'm that that I'm trying
to stress to all of you guys is that I
shouldn't be seeing this stuff and there
are things you can do to your code to
obfuscate it not encrypt it but
obfuscate it and make this unable to be
read now you're probably thinking but
Alyssa it's possible to decode it that
is true but at least make it harder for
me at least make it hard for me to
actually do it and spend time on it
we're all mode 2 and other companies app
and go after that that's not using
application shielding one of the
solutions is the company that that
sponsored this research they actually
have tamper detection where it will
actually phone home and warn the company
that I'm that I'm actually messing
around with their app so there are tools
I'm not here to tell you guys that this
guy is falling I'm here to show you how
bad it can be if you guys don't pay
attention to what you're doing when
you're writing these apps or you know
when you're generating a key believe it
or not you guys ready for this a lot of
the banks weren't even using OAuth yeah
a lot of them were just using API access
keys it's there's a lot of really bad
stuff going on in the financial
institutions and financial services
where they're they're not doing a lot of
basic security stuff so this is what
happens when you don't so again more API
keys more URLs you guys can see some
more euros in there you know it's it's
just again if I have the URL I know what
to go after if I have the API you're all
I know what to target private key
private key that's hard-coded in the
code like seriously like if you guys
you're like hey Lissa um it's a random
letters and numbers how did you like go
searching in that code for all these
private keys how did you know what to
look for uh do you guys see that comment
right there begin DSA private key it's
that's all I searched for man it's like
I just searched for begin DSA private
key and it and I found everything it was
like said 29 out of the 30 here's one
know what the xxx app was that was more
secure you guys you guys think it was a
multi-billion dollar bank with billions
under assets it was one of the smaller
cryptocurrency while it startup
companies yeah you guys were like oh you
know this is crazy I bet some of these
findings that Alisa showing us our small
startups and you know they don't have
the the budget or the developers or
whatever to make sure this is being done
right no these are the findings from
large large multinational banks the the
more secure apps the ones that were more
hardened were the smaller startups the
small businesses really really
interesting so yeah private key right
there in the code okay
this was interesting so you got I cooked
up the logo but I'm sure you guys
recognize who that is that API
documentation for who that is but
basically you specify a publish and
subscribe and a channel name and so
again you can see here in the code all I
did was I did some OSA it's the most
open source intelligence collection I
went to the API documentation I found
out what I'm looking for
I found out oh I need to look for
something called subscribe key and I
went in there and I grouped it I found
it
okay so again I don't know maybe you
guys are like Alyssa you totally suck
that's stupid we're not going to protect
our API documentation it shouldn't be
secured it should be available to the
world you know we're gonna keep your car
okay but I mean challenge me let's
spar over it like I don't think this
should be freely available at least make
me create an account at least make me
prove I'm a developer that's going to
actually legitimately write something
for this right but this is freely
available without a registration gate
okay looking for a company name okay you
guys can probably tell from the
directory names and the file names what
kind of company this is but you know
this is this is scary and this is like
there's there's just so much stuff now
okay you're probably thinking okay
Alyssa this is really cool and stuff but
did you actually try these keys and try
these tokens and trailer yes yes I would
have be on stage unless I actually
tested it free rein free rein to the
database a lot of these is just they
weren't one of the bank's one of the
banks was assuming that once you
presented that key you had already
successfully authenticated logic flaw
right so okay if I have a key it means
that I have authenticated right it's so
the logic and the server was that oh
Alyssa's presenting me this key it must
mean she's successfully authenticated
logic flaw all right I had access to
everything in the database so again no
no oh there's a company name there
pretend you didn't see that
so yes you guys that's a password
password right there and it's an
extremely big Bank really big bank okay
that's a password hard-coded in the
source code ah revisit this this
particular Bank was the one that was
doing private keys with no passwords I
mean at least put it in the source code
that was a joke by the way
okay raise your hand if you know what an
initialization vector is five minutes
cool okay yeah cool hard-coded Ivy's in
the source code you don't number one wet
like you could actually crack a wet key
because of the IV :
you you could it would let you crack the
WEP key on a Wi-Fi network sending
initialization vectors hard-coded in the
source code along with the key AWS
credentials secret keys access keys
session tokens private keys and
certificates were hard-coded in the code
hard-coded tokens access token zoos for
authentication initial findings were
hard-coded public private keys tokens
credentials and certificates then
realized many of the API servers were
authenticating only using the API key no
token no username password were required
many of the FI zone sensitive
information was protected while
third-party critical apps such as
payment processors cloud services and
other third-party credentials were not
s3 buckets s3 buckets sort of kind of a
little bit of data there for me to fish
around in just a little that was a joke
ok I'm running out of time list of more
WTF I name is credential passive reset
your eyes continue actual oh yeah don't
put tokens and keys in the actual URI
you guys know why you shouldn't do that
region if you never will know why you
should not do that ok cool there's some
in here because it shows up in the logs
and the refers if I'm going to a website
in the token or the key isn't in UI it
shows up in the and the refer refer
refer refer it shows up like don't do it
don't do it
third-party integrations were incredibly
insecure
oh yeah the own the banks or financial
institutions own app was not as jacked
the third-party integrations for payment
processors when you pay your bill
through the app or transfer money to
someone were incredibly insecure IAS
tokens and private keys with no
passwords more bad stuff sorry I know
they're gonna kick me out the stage
payment stuff oh this is the director of
keys yes it's actually called a merged
private in public key there's no
passwords on Ian's
stuff all right what can we do basic ste
for encoding is not encryption shield
your apps with code obfuscation tamper
detection so sensitive information such
as yours keys and credentials are
protected I mean taking in dirty of your
API starting with external exposed api's
develop a security policies including
authentication authorization be pay
users traffic management content threat
detection use an API security gateway
and static and dynamic code analysis
tools penetration testing at pen testing
static analysis remove our tokenized
sense of date and your eyes and
continuously review continuous
monitoring and contains improvement of
your security stock me add me on Twitter
right now add me on LinkedIn I'm gonna
be incredibly offended if you don't I
know who you are
that's my mobile number if you want to
call and hang up like some kind of
creepy stalker guy that's cool too if
you want to be the long-distance charges
that's fine
Instagram medium YouTube
Thank You Alyssa we have time for one
question from the audience
right someone who muster them all who
think it's not possible to make these
mistakes right I wasn't that good you
guys got up questions great presentation
I had a question you analyzed the
organic threats inside the app itself
but what about that let's say a
particular mobile banking app that's
running on Android on the phone having
you know runtime analysis so like
actually executing instead of dead code
or lateral threats like some other
malware on the phone attacking yeah so
that was that was out of scope for this
testing so the 30 banks there is a part
two of my research coming out everybody
which is why I said add me on twitter
follow me there's a part two coming in a
few weeks and that is the dynamic code
analysis the other kind of even believe
it or not is worse than this so there's
a lot of apps that are not using
encryption everybody add your s and HTTP
so yes but no that was idris cope for
the testing thank you yeah quick maybe
it was just a quick idea with your
opinion but would you still agree that
security so two things often people say
that security was too important to let
other do it in the 90s now security is
too important to do it yourself right
then if they're able to do that right
yeah what do you agree with that yes no
I can argue both sides of the that I can
play devil's advocate if you don't have
the internal resources definitely
outsource it so somebody is doing it the
problem is that there is a global talent
shortage in cybersecurity and it is
really tough for organizations to find
senior penetration testers or senior
security engineers who can secure their
code and secure their products and
because of that they're having to rely
on outsourcing because they get the
thing is of that why am I going to go
work for a company at 175 thousand a
year
when I can go out there and bill it for
$100 an hour right it doesn't make sense
so I'm gonna go w2 so the the global
talent shortage is affecting us and I
think is actually perpetuating this
problem okay and the second thing about
about security sometimes people say
actually you have just to be more secure
than your competitors so hikers will go
to the weakest link right right would
you still agree with that oh yeah
hackers are inherently lazy I am
probably the laziest person you'll ever
meet
I will go the path of least resistance
if I have to spend more time on your
code because you've Auto skated it I'm
gonna give you the middle finger and I'm
gonna go down with somebody else's app
so yeah it's path of least resistance
a hacker unless they're specifically
targeting you unless they're
specifically targeting you we'll move on
to a weaker link yep thank you very much
Alisa thank you for you oh thank you
[Applause]